TV land sure isn't the cozy safe haven it
used to be.
In recent years, dedicated viewers have lost
beloved characters on everything from Game
of Thrones to Stranger Things to even Will
and Grace.
So far, it looks like 2018 is shaping up to
be another small-screen bloodbath.
Get the tissues ready, because we're looking
back at a few characters who've unexpectedly
left us in 2018 - but be careful if you're
not caught up on these shows, because this
one's loaded with …
"Spoilers."
Carl - The Walking Dead
Carl Grimes - and actor Chandler Riggs, for
that matter - grew up on TV.
The son of Walking Dead protagonist Rick Grimes,
he'd been with the series since it started
in 2010.
Along the way, he endured tragedies and setbacks,
including the loss of his mother during childbirth,
the loss of an eye, and various acts of evil
by villains like the Governor and Negan.
Keeping Carl alive and safe was the reason
Rick never completely crumbled, and Carl kept
human decency alive 'til the end - which is
what ultimately killed him.
"Carl's dead."
Carl left Alexandria to help the mysterious
Siddiq mercy-kill zombies because Siddiq believed
it freed their souls.
Turned out one of those zombies took a bite
out of Carl - as zombies do.
It was a death sentence, but not an immediate
one, giving Carl enough time to say goodbye.
He hung out with his little sister Judith,
wrote devastating farewell letters to Enid,
Michonne, and Rick, and then - so his end
could be on his own terms - he shot himself
offscreen before he could go full walker.
Tobin - The Walking Dead
Fans have always had mixed feelings about
Tobin, a resident of Alexandria who first
showed up in Season 5.
On the one hand, his relationship with Carol
was interesting, but on the other hand, he
just up and abandoned Francine to a zombie
attack in order to save his own skin.
Well, fans no longer have to feel conflicted
about Tobin, because he's dead.
Thanks to an infected stab wound, Tobin turned
into a zombie and killed several of his former
allies before being put down for good by Carol.
Talk about a bad way to go out!
Simon - The Walking Dead
There's an old saying among Walking Dead fans:
lie down with zombie dogs, you get zombie
fleas.
Simon found that out the hard way.
As the second in command to the Walking Dead's
cartoonishly evil Negan, it was only a matter
of time before he found himself staring down
Lucille's business end.
And sure enough, Negan finally got tired of
Simon plotting behind his back, leading to
a one-on-one showdown that ultimately ended
with Simon's zombified corpse being strung
up as a warning.
Yikes!
Nick Clark - Fear the Walking Dead
Fear the Walking Dead has always played second
fiddle to its parent show, The Walking Dead.
So in season four, AMC attempted to fix that
by bringing in a bunch of new faces, along
with classic Walking Dead character Morgan.
All those additions meant there had to be
some subtractions.
And the most shocking was the loss of Frank
Dillane's Nick Clark, who was at the center
of many of the show's storylines over the
first three seasons.
Dillane had reportedly asked to be written
off the series, though, making it an easy
choice for producers, who disposed of Clark
by having Charlie, a tween working as a mole
for a different survival group, shoot him
dead.
Cigarette Smoking Man, Skinner, and Reyes
- The X-Files
Love it or hate it, one thing's for certain:
The X-Files' season 11 finale aimed to shock.
One of the season's main arcs concerned Cigarette
Smoking Man's plans to unleash a lethal virus
on the world, and to pull it off, he'd manipulated
Scully's shape-shifting son William, along
with FBI Assistant Director Walter Skinner
and Agent Monica Reyes, into helping him execute
it.
CSM - portrayed with ominous perfection by
William B. Davis - also happened to be William's
biological father.
Yup, he was the one who'd drugged and medically
impregnated Scully nearly two decades ago.
William, wishing to be free of all this evil
awfulness, finally confronted CSM on a dock
while using his powers to disguise himself
as Mulder.
CSM then shot William-as-Mulder in the head.
Then the real Mulder, distraught and devastated,
shot CSM a bunch of times and shoved him into
the water.
This means that one of the series' biggest
and most memorable big bads is finally gone.
However, he caused some collateral damage
on the way: Earlier in the episode, after
Skinner shot one-time Scully replacement Agent
Monica Reyes, the FBI Assistant Director was
apparently run over with a car driven by CSM.
Maybe.
Honestly, is anybody ever really deceased
on The X-Files?
Even William burst out of the water at the
end of the episode, so who knows for sure?
"Everyone still dies in the end."
Ferguson - New Girl
Fox's New Girl isn't so new anymore, and it's
come to the end of its seven-season run with
a handful of episodes that wrapped up all
of its loose ends and gave each of its characters
a proper send-off.
Nick and Jess have finally gotten together
for good, Schmidt and CeCe have a young daughter
named Ruth, Winston and an extremely pregnant
Aly are expecting … and, at some point during
the three-year time jump between seasons,
someone passed away.
"Ferguson died of a heart attack."
"What?"
"Yes, the coroner said nothing about glitter."
"Did you say coroner?"
That would be Ferguson, the beloved smush-faced
cat belonging to Winston.
Winston acquired Ferguson back in season two
- she belonged to a girlfriend, and when she
cheated on him, he found peace by adopting
the cat.
While viewers were spared the not-very-sitcom-friendly
images and emotional turmoil of watching a
pet pass away, New Girl devoted an episode
to Winston's over-the-top grieving process,
which involves a motorcade to an elaborate
memorial service conducted in the Jewish tradition.
Spencer - American Housewife
A relatable family sitcom injected with a
hefty dose of social satire, ABC's American
Housewife concerns a middle-class family trying
to keep their values and decency in check
while living in the ultra-rich and superficial
town of Westport, Connecticut.
The middle child Oliver is determined to be
as rich as his peers someday.
Part of that involved befriending a new neighbor,
a disgraced Wolf of Wall Street type just
released from prison named Spencer, played
by George Hamilton.
While Oliver initially intended to just be
nice to get in the old guy's will, a true
friendship and grandfather/grandson relationship
developed.
He kept Oliver in check against the greed
of the community, which is why it was so shocking
that American Housewife writers had him pass
away late in the second season.
Clayton Reeves - NCIS
NCIS wound down its 15th season with a heavily
promoted plot: The departure of original character
Abby, whose longtime portrayer, actress Pauley
Perrette, was ready to move on.
NCIS fans suspected that Abby might be written
off the show the way characters are most commonly
and effectively removed from a series: by
putting them 6 feet under.
It certainly appeared that this fate had befallen
lab tech Abby, especially since in what was
Perrette's second-to-last episode, she and
co-worker Clayton Reeves struggled over a
gun with a yet-to-be-identified assailant.
Then, a gunshot rang out as the screen cut
to black.
The following episode depicted Ducky sympathizing
with another coroner about the agony of performing
an autopsy on a former colleague.
And then, as the body bag is unzipped, Reeves
is shown inside.
Evidently, he'd selflessly stepped in front
of Abby to take the bullet.
As for Abby, she was in the hospital, but
she pulled through, and played an integral
role in one last high-stakes NCIS adventure.
Artie Goodman - Unbreakable Kimmy Schmidt
At the end of season three, Unbreakable Kimmy
Schmidt's resident grump, Lillian, had unexpectedly
found true love with Artie Goodman, her rival
in a battle over neighborhood gentrification.
But at the start of season four, fans got
a surprise when it was revealed that Artie
had unexpectedly died, leaving Lillian in
charge of disposing of his ashes.
She eventually did it in her own signature
fashion, selling two plastic baggies of his
remains for $1,200 to some folks who clearly
thought those ashes were something a little
more party-friendly.
Butch and R'as al Ghul - Gotham
Deaths on Gotham are frequent, but they're
usually just underlings, stooges, or random
victims of the future Rogue's Gallery.
In the season four finale, though, two major
bad guys bit the dust.
Bruce, aka the former Solomon Grundy, was
executed by the Penguin, though being an immortal
swamp monster might reverse that in future
seasons.
Meanwhile, Ra's al Ghul was stabbed to death
by Barbara, with a little help from the only
person who can kill him for good, Bruce Wayne.
Of course, Ra's also has a habit of returning
from the dead thanks to his Lazarus Pit, but
for now, he's among this year's list of shocking
casualties.
Will Simpson - Jessica Jones
In the first season of Jessica Jones, good
guy cop Will Simpson turned out to actually
be a total creeper with a dark and mysterious
past that involved government experiments
gone wrong.
It seemed he was being set up to become the
comic book anti-hero Nuke.
That expectation was confounded in season
two, though.
Yes, he was totally stalking Trish, but after
she confronted him, it turned out he was trying
to warn her about someone even more dangerous
- a someone who then promptly snapped his
neck.
So much for that subplot!
Jack - This Is Us
Due to the show's non-linear, flashback-heavy
structure, the millions of rabid fans of NBC's
smash hit tearjerker This Is Us knew that
Pearson patriarch Jack - played by Milo Ventimiglia
- was going to die, but they weren't quite
sure how.
This Is Us used its post-Super Bowl time slot
to deliver a very special episode on February
4th, revealing exactly what led to Pearson's
passing.
The previous episode ended with a flashback
sequence set in 1998, showing the family's
slow cooker short out and spark a massive
fire that quickly engulfs the Pearson home.
Jack wakes up in the middle of the night and
turns into Hero Dad, getting his family out
of the house with a bedsheet rope.
His wife Rebecca takes him to the hospital
to attend to his minor burns.
Then she steps out of the room for just a
second… long enough for an ER doctor to
tell her that Jack passed away of cardiac
arrest brought on by smoke inhalation.
"Your husband went into cardiac arrest.
It was catastrophic and…
I-I'm afraid we've lost him."
We're not ugly crying!
You're ugly crying!
Thanks for watching!
Click the Looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel.
Plus check out all this cool stuff we know
you'll love, too!